hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's sorry for the long delay I've
had a lot of other things to get to and
there's a lot of games that I need to
play you guys have been great about
giving me suggestions so as always write
them in the comments below but I'm gonna
get to the sixth night of this game and
I'm gonna fail miserably over and over
and over and over again because that's
all I can do I literally have no other
potential hello
I'm not supposed to be here one you do
know that you don't have to be here
today right
I mean well I guess you're just very
committed to the job then anyway you've
done a great job this week so now please
take three tomorrow okay now see you
next week good night wait that's all
you're gonna say about me you told me
about a secret room before a secret room
right there or the parts for employees
door I mean that was all bad right
unless it was good I mean I don't think
it was good I know a good thing when I
see it and it's probably not that oh god
I forgot oh god you're being a little
too active for my taste thank you very
much I have other what was that what the
hell that was a mouse why was there a
mouse Oh what huh why was there a mouse
boy I might have missed a memo here but
I thought this was five nights at
candy's
candy being a kitty cat tell me some new
now huh oh no that a-maz come from or
are oh shut up I already know the deal
I'm gonna die
I shouldn't be here today
newse road to come in today oh god there
but there glide there I see you what the
hell what is with that that's a bunch of
baloney
where are you there where did you come
from what are you what are you I don't
know
I don't think me shouting it that's
probably bad oh hello
well where's where's the goddamn where's
a goddamn thing like this this is where
news ah you're not supposed to be over
there my god
Frick was that where you like that why
are you why do you do those things to me
well that's not good now I got Momo in
that to worry about
I mean Momo was bad enough not I just
said Momo was bad to his face very rude
hello oh man I can't get lazy I can't be
scratching my arm these nights are long
and full of tears like penguins penguin
tears man
oh god oh god oh god oh god hello oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god it's
not okay oh god no oh god no oh god this
night is going to be a [ __ ]
I mean sassafras basically god I just
need to juggle the doors close the
entire time and maybe hope fire run out
of power ha ha ha
maybe doing a new Medusa doosh doosh
doosh doosh doosh doosh doosh doosh
doosh I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna
try juggling the doors pretty much
because if I can do that then I can pull
off a miracle because there is a bit of
a strategy that I mean the doors take
more power the longer that they stay
closed so that means I can be a little
more judicial about what I'm doing this
is probably not the ideal strategy to
just be juggling these doors like this I
mean tell me what else I should do I
don't know I can't do that yet
okay that's that now we got that out the
way I cannot use a little bit of power
and stop panicking so goddamn much you
know death is encroaching from all
directions and I'm gonna die from death
because death is all I've got to go
through here and why do I gotta be
working alone in this place you think
that they could hire another shift or
something because I mean goddamn being
alone here kind of sucks I mean I know
I'm not one to complain about the job
market being bad and all that and I
understand the nicely I'm grateful that
I have a job at all but I mean come on
Rousey wowsie wowsie wowsie not too
friendly win where's Momo
Oh Missoula way back there now zero zero
anyone II pass you a cigar Imani
Master Wesson leave me alone II won't I
am NOT do good yeah I mean I'm not want
to complain about the economy but
frankly this kind of smooth I mean a lot
of balls I mean like 23 different sets
of balls going on at once
I mean not saying like I'm an expert in
that or anything I don't know find him
quantify it in a certain way
quality quantifiable in a number of sets
of balls in someone's I should shut up
you know when I'm in a stressful
situation I don't exactly know what to
say at all times and I am probably gonna
run out of power any time now Oh God
needs again with your
it's hard to be quick about this it is
hard as I'm not gonna take it anymore
oh god mo oh no oh god that was a bit
too close on that one
mo mo you're a big man beg beg beg beg
kitty pretty kitty
man I wasted a lot of power in the
beginning of this I shouldn't have been
so [ __ ] about keeping everything
closed but I was just a little paranoid
what was that oh hey it's the radhika's
okay so the Radhika's is on the way
god damn this house go hard to spot oh
that's cases coming over as hard is hard
is hard is hard I guess just move you
ass
oh my ba ba oh god damn it
ah [ __ ] goddamn I've run way too low on
power oh man that was close
dang I'm smart I can only hope that mr.
blank face doesn't brick and do nothing
to me yeah again making it to 4:00 a.m.
on the three bo God that was something
oh mama mama mama mama mama mo mo mo mo
go go go go mama thank you I gotta save
every scrap of power I got you guys
frankly old man you do hard to spot oh
god rat on that side that's not even
fair he's gone gotta be very sparing
about my power okay he's gone alrighty
Lee that rat I don't know where that rat
came from but I don't much appreciate it
oh hey good see ya can you go the [ __ ]
away never come back three blanks being
good G bars power left which is not God
beginning come on turn over to 5:00 a.m.
all right eh
damn it [ __ ] oh god there's fire not
gonna last hours not gonna last
guarantee you dad I was not gonna last
blows is gonna be close this is gonna be
right down to the goddamn wire whoa
Radhika's whoa Radhey Radhey Radhey baby
whoa ready oh I really hope that blank
is not being a dick right now oh I
really hope if this is hard to follow I
apologize I'm moving rather quickly
Oh God hello
not okay buddy
Cindy is that you baby Cindy I told you
never call me again we're over we're
through what we had was just very brief
one of our nine lives I've got other
lives to live
I gotta explore the world you know oh
who was that Hot Diggity damn I am
impressed with myself hot dog I was
incredible oh hey it's a whole family
even radhika's
Radhika's Momo Blanc all one big happy
oh-oh they're singing a song kumbaya
not okay oh that's why they were in that
position they were just tired this is
going buddy all right a kiss sure is a
nice guy
glad II stopped by hey Mary Schmidt I
did it I got some overtime
anyway car thousand ninety six of five
nights of candy sounds pretty tough but
I didn't manage to do it because I used
too much power in the menu there I had
to be very sparing towards Ian but I had
a system down so if 97 doesn't introduce
a rogue element that is even worse and
pump up everyone else too horrifying
levels I should be fine right
hahahaha probably okay so that's to stir
Oh custom the extra let me see what is
this oh okay cool candy
Cindy Chester Aden Pangu blank Momo rat
what is it Oh God
okay then oh look it's adorable
hahahaha one of us is gonna stop and uh
nope Oh nope no no no
alrighty then so we're just gonna leave
it on this very silent and creepy so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I might try the custom night which I
imagine yep that's ok there you 7:20
mode I don't think I'm going to succeed
at that let me just give you a little
taste of what this is gonna be like
because I imagine it's gonna be bad
probably is maybe the a Medtronic that
is me actually comes storming down the
halls no don't be good oh no I'm too
happy for that
oh hello
a little plushie I got love hello
was that there was something up there
there was something on the bookshelf did
you guys see that there was something on
the bookshelf in camera six on top of
there I saw something on the bookshelf
there was something on the bookshelf I
mean these guys are coming on heavy but
besides oh no I got damnit
so there was 720 mode which I had been
if I had been paying it a bit more
typically if I had been paying a bit
more attention I might have been doing
okay on that but anyway that was 96 I
don't know how long it's gonna take me
to be my knight 7 but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of this series and
thank you for watching throughout the
entire series and being so patient on
this episode coming out thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video oh excuse me
ah you feeling ok there buck we